what is going on everybody welcome to
another python tutorial video in this
video we're talking about function
argument unpacking so a neat little
trick that you can do to either further
shorten your code or even obfuscate your
code as function argument on packing and
the reason why i'd consider this office
keishon it's purely because a lot of
people never seen a really heard of this
or if they did they didn't really quite
know what was going on when they did so
it can kind of be useful for that but
also you can knock out you know lines of
your code if you're really looking to
condense something so the idea of it is
to literally unpack the variables for a
function for the same purpose that we
would you know unpack variables with num
pies load text for example so it kind of
saves a step in a fairly common
operation so with that let's go ahead
and get started so let's say we've got a
function and is called do something and
it does something with x and y and what
it does is pretty crazy it's going to
print X and print why next now let's say
we have x and y but x and y is in the
form of a list so coordinates one and
it's going to be 2175 so typically if
you wanted to pass you know 21 is X and
75 as Y in the arguments here the way
you would you know probably do it in one
line would be do something cords 10
comma cords 11 right but instead what
you can do is function argument i'm
packing use an asterisk or also refer to
as a splat and say cords one so now we
say this and we run this what's going to
happen is it's going to go ahead and
print out 2175 s21 is X Y is 75 pretty
neat so now the other thing you can do
is use it with dictionaries so to do it
with a dictionary let's say you've got
chords 2 equals and in curly braces we
start our dictionary and here we have x
and x equals let's say five this time
and y equals six this time and now
instead of towards one and will delete
the previous splat this
actually takes two asterisks or two
splats and then you would say cords too
right so now we're expecting a 56 so
let's go ahead and save and run that and
sure enough we do indeed get a 56 so
again just to reiterate the reason why
we're using two here is because we're
unpacking a dictionary at least in my
little head the way I envisioned it is
you know you've got a it's unpacking
this and then this right so it's kind of
needing to go too deep so it uses two
asterisks not sure anyway um that's that
now let's say another thing you could do
is something like this right so you can
use kind of pre-built functions right so
if you have print range 2175 for example
let's delete this and really we can
delete all of this Wow will do this okay
so if we do this we put that range you
know that's the range function is just
kind of like built-in right so it prints
out a range of 21 and 75 you can do the
same thing with a built-in function so
you could say print range towards one
like that splat words run rather print
and you indeed get the same print out of
the actual range itself so kind of Annie
a little-known functionality built
within Python again can be used either
as just kind of save either lines of
code or even like just how how much you
know stuff you're stuffing into this
function here so that concludes this
tutorial as always hopefully you guys
enjoyed thanks for watching things for
all the support of the subscriptions and
until the next video